well I don't believe you'll ever reduce
the unemployment rate in any meaningful
way with stimulus in other words with
government spending because once the
stimulus is spent generally the jobs are
gone what we need to do is revitalize
our banks where they can make loans to
small and medium-sized businesses and
let the market work the market
ultimately is probably going to be the
only thing that that brings unemployment
down from the high levels that they are
today
well I have never to my knowledge voted
for taxes I don't plan to vote for him
in the future because the the spinning
of the government will always outrun the
taxes we have programs that are in fact
right now we're spending too much in
taxes if we tax everybody ninety percent
it wouldn't take care of our problems it
might aid and abet someone but then we
take that money out of people's pockets
and we do real damage to the economy so
if people are advocating taxes is a way
to close our deficit I think that's a
short term and I think it's a flawed
argument
well I believe a flat tax would be fair
for a lot of reasons I have advocated
the flat tax on a number of occasions
one it would lower people's taxes tax
burden they would have more money to
spend that have more that'd be good for
the economy they have more money to say
which would be good for future
investment and job creation in this
country and the in the family under my
proposal a family of four that made I
believe thirty six thousand eight
hundred dollars would pay no taxes at
all we would become a nation of savers
and status spenders and there would not
be deductions because you wouldn't need
them you'd have more discretionary money